18 décembre 94 le 7 de la rue du dragon
devient l'adresse la plus célèbre de
france
droit au logement investi un immeuble
vacant du groupe immobilier cogedim une
réquisition commando pour y loger plus
d'une centaine de personnes premiers
arrivants jean-lous à fait comme les
autres à libérer les lieux chômeurs il
ya un an il est de nouveau salarié et
attend désormais son nouveau logement
plus ou moins 192 nations
j'ai habité puis ouvrage me plaisait
d'abord si on jouait dans 93 genre 3 13
puis c'est tout je peux chercher à
discuter tout ce que je veux c'est mon
relogement du cto un droit désormais
acquis après de longues négociations
menées par le dal avec les propriétaires
la préfecture de police et des bailleurs
sociaux
vingt-six familles sont assurés d'une
place en hlm du luxe comparé refuge du
dragon privés de chauffage est soumise à
une promiscuité de moins en moins
supporté par les occupants un départ
dont la reconnaissance mais sans regret
ou inexistence que l'on n'aurait jamais
dû quitter
est-ce que là j'ai quand même met à
chercher du travail lâcherait fixe il a
rappelé à bouger jeu pourra trouver une
école j'aurais une vie normale il y aura
toujours des petits problèmes et ça tout
on en est là j'aurais une vie normale -
en vous rappelant ce qui ne sera pas le
cas pour une centaine d'autres
pensionnaires relogées dans le cadre du
plan périssol des logements d'urgence
est provisoire
haas a certainement qu'on va les suivre
comme on a suivi les gens qui ont été
relogés par la rue béranger l'immeuble
de la rue béranger la rue condorcet ou
autres c'est des gens qu'on suit encore
régulièrement avec la fin du dragon
prévue mi-janvier une page se tourne
mais dans les fichiers du dal reste à
suivre 7000 dossiers en souffrance